Hi, I'm Christopher Hine. Today I'm
going to talk a little bit about Kagash.
So, I'm just going to bring it up
because I brought it up in the last
perspective video on the new perspective
for Nagaywaza video. And I feel like
there's a lot to talk about with Kotag
because I think Kagashi is kind of this
really important technique actually for
what previously was talked about in
classic jiu-jitsu and for what we're
doing in iikido. And I think honestly
the way at least I see Iikido whether
anyone else saw it that way or not um
its importance kind of has this shift
and I think that's kind of why it got
put in this limbo and in my opinion
quote kind of sits in a limbo. Um so I'm
going to talk a little bit about that.
I'm g get Josh over here. We're gonna go
to work. Josh.
All right. So let's
that was exciting. Let's talk a little
bit about kotish. Um so kodish is I
think like this really key technique for
some things like you you couldn't have
this kind of system without the
existence of kodish kodash culturally
exists in a whole lot of places you can
see it in old European manuscripts you
can see it in Chinese manuscripts you
can see it in all kinds of places it is
a key technique however kind of I think
it's not as useful for the new ideas of
kodaiish so for example in the kilowaza.
I think it didn't get stuck in there
because it's not as important for the
stuff we do. So, it just kind of is
floating around. Okay. So, let's talk
about these big three that used to exist
um as these three names iconically. And
I think this goes back to the Kobukan,
the old school Yoshiba dojo. So, you
have uh Kot Haneeri and we now call that
Sanio, Kot Moashi, we now call that Nio.
and Kotagish, which we still call
Kotagish. Those three cannot be
separated from weapon grappling centric
stuff. You can't pull them out because
those are the ways you get knives out of
someone's hand or a sword or a spear or
whatever it is you're going to take out
of someone's hand, you have to use those
three. They're they're really really
key. Kotag, in my opinion, is the king
of those because most of the time Josh
is going to orient his elbow down. So,
he's going to be try to be elbow down.
So most of the time I'm going to be
working the wrist this way to to disarm
him, right? So the kotashi is the key
one. Now of course if he forces it
opposite we'll get kot moashi or kote
haneeri. So nikio or sanio depending on
if his elbow goes above my arm or goes
below my arm and he rolls his arm over
but with his arm down which is going to
be his normal position then I'm gonna
get kaggish. When I'm teaching knife
disarm stuff, I call kodish our number
one because it's the number one
technique when we're looking at
disarming. It just it is your number
your number one and called Niko number
two because to me it's the second best
and most likely right. So kaggos is a
king technique in lots of ways but for
iikido context as far as like I see it
and what I think kind of the evolution
of it is it's not as useful because look
so we are going to disarm people so that
is a part of it but look if Josh has me
here I can get a kodish this way it's a
little bit awkward right we we have the
technique I teach the technique I use
the technique so it comes up but it's a
little bit awkward
much more awkward than this. This is
much more natural. So, this is probably
going to be your go-to. And that's
Nikio's second second principle, right?
Okay. So, we can use kodish, but it's
probably a little more awkward in the
other sense. If Josh is up here, okay,
now if I circle this way, this is a
really natural way to get and Josh
didn't want to give it to me there, but
it's a really natural way to get the the
nikio, right? So the kot washing but to
get the kodish you have to go like this
and this and totally doable but it's
really not the kodagish that's working
as much as this elbow that's working to
to get him free right so for making
hodoki kodish is just not quite on the
same level as say a nikio is right so in
my opinion it's like it's just not quite
as good at that when we're talking about
disarming of course it's king but when
we're talking about not trying to
grapple I'm not really going to use it
that much. So a lot of the kiosa the
functionality is going to come more in
the situations of either hodoki or
doiwaza ocomi waza, right? So holding or
take down pinning techniques. Okay, now
look, Nikio can do a good job of taking
him down because it puts a ton of force
and he collapses down. Kotish really
doesn't take him down. Now as I talked
about in the throwing video, I can step
back here and make that work. But this
is all kind of inherently dangerous
because Josh can always wrap around,
right? It's really hard to avoid that
wraparound. I have to catch just a
perfect moment in time to avoid that
wraparound. So, it's not really that
good of a takedown technique. It's not a
good holding technique. So, if I had
Josh in Sancho, right? So, Koteri and
Josh comes to hit me, he can't because I
can control the other side. Meaning, if
he turns into me this way, he gets
cranked here. Nikio is the same way. I
have him here and he turns into me, he
gets cranked. Kagash I can crank him
hard but his action of turning in
doesn't hurt him at all. So it doesn't
have the kind of holding power that
Sanio or Nikio has, right? And Sanio is
really good at that holding power,
right? So it kind of has this in modern
Iikido this kind of like well it's a
great technique for one thing but it
doesn't have the power of the rest of
the Kyowaza, right? So to me the other
Kyoaza kind of have more use, right?
Even if you get into something like
Yonko, which in my opinion is kind of
underplayed in Iikido, I can use Yonko
every time I grab him, right? So if I
grabbed him katate, I'm yonoing him,
right? I can grab him yak. I can grab
him any way I grab him. If I grab him
with my hands, I can use the technique
of uh Yonkyo. Now Gokyo is like, well,
is Gokyo better than um Kagash? I bet
they're pretty close to equal when
you're talking about just disarming and
how often that's going to come up. So,
it doesn't really merit being part of
the killwaza in a lot of ways, but it
also can't be removed from the system
because it's so powerful really at one
thing, which is disarming. It's really,
really good for disarming. So, it gets
caught in this kind of crummy position.
And I also think the highfall from it is
so nice to take that we like to like
capitalize upon. Look, I can throw a guy
with just his little wrist. And it's so
obvious with that. That's not as obvious
with Nikio. It's not as obvious with
Sankio, right? So, so you can see how
Kotagashi makes it look like you're
really cool and powerful. So, then it
kind of becomes iconic for Iikido and
then we're kind of stuck with it. And
I'm not saying it should be totally
removed from the system, but it's not
quite as good as the Kyoaza. Now, if I
wanted to really revise things and and I
don't want to do this, then I would just
make it the seventh or eighth kilowaza,
right? Like that's what I would just
tack it on to the end and say, "Oh, it's
a kill wasn't now." But it is this
iconic thing. And so you I I I don't
want to do that. So it's kind of stuck
in this limbo land. Um and that's why
it's stuck in this limbo land in my
opinion. Um I I hope that was useful to
you. I don't know. Was it useful? Yeah.
All right. Good. Yeah. Josh agrees. All
right. So I'm Christopher. This is
Joshua Te. My salon McDaniel's behind
that camera right there and we'll see
you in a future video.